pandemic we have the pleasure of having
today with us
president fonda lyon and president is
accompanied by her special adviser
peter piotr professor peter piatt
is a belgian microbiologist known for
his research
into ebola and aids after helping
to discover the ebola virus in 1976
and leading efforts to contain the first
ever recorded ebola epidemic
that same year peter piatt became a
pioneering
researcher into aids he has held
key positions in the united nations and
world health
organization involving aids research
and management he is currently director
of the london school of hygiene
and tropical medicine
pita piatt is connected with us today
through the same interaction system that
we use
for our daily midday briefing so i ask
for your patience
in terms of the technicalities of the
use of the system
we have today interpretation from and
into
french english german
spanish italian polish
greek latvian dutch
and danish as well as international
sign language president van der laan
will first make
a statement followed by professor piatt
we will then move to the q a session
we will focus first and foremost on
questions on today's
package and i can already announce to
you today that the president
will be back in the press room on the
first of december for further press
conference
after one year of mandate president from
the line you have the floor
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this means that everyone can and
everyone
must contribute what we are expected to
do
is simple we need to wear masks
and stick to hand hygiene and we need to
avoid the three
seas crowds close contacts
and closed spaces with poor ventilation
and only by protecting ourselves and
each other
we can reduce the spread of the virus
and thus reduce the
impact on our lives and our livelihoods
for example is
we have remedied initial shortages of
medical and other counter measures
through risk eu stockpiling and working
with manufacturers
we initiate a joint procurement for
protective personal equipment
ventilators and intensive care medicine
we insisted on lifting national export
restrictions
for critical supplies and we
suspended customs duties and vit on such
items
we set up green lanes to allow the
proper functioning of the single market
and transport
we introduced a coordinated approach to
travel restrictions
based on common color codes for risk
zones
and we concluded so far three
advanced purchase agreements for safe
and effective vaccines so that they can
be available to all member states
at the same time on the same conditions
three others are now in the pipeline
now we must build on these foundations
with additional measures
and taken together the package we
presented today
enables a coordinated approach to data
sharing
to testing to medical and non-medical
equipment
to travel and to vaccination strategies
we are all in this together
no member state will safely emerge from
the crisis
until everyone does and that
is why you will hear us stress the need
for cooperation
coordination and solidarity
tomorrow the heads of state and
government
will meet virtually the aim is better
coordination
i will call for greater data sharing
to the data platform with ecdc
this will help us to know for example
where there is icu capacity or
cross-border patient care can be
organized when needed
we will also set up a european platform
of national science advisors to covet
in order to exchange and align the
advice given to the different
governments we recommend
effective and coordinated testing
strategies in the
package of today and we recommend
increasing capacity for testing
rapid antigen tests are now coming to
the market
this can play a significant role
but we will propose a eu approach
to approval and use because only then
there will be mutual recognition of
tests and
of tests results
for our part we are now mobilizing 100
million euros
from the emergency support instrument to
purchase
rapid tests that we will then distribute
to the member states
and we launch a joint procurement
to make more available
we call on all member states to link up
national apps to the european gateway in
november
we call on member states to participate
in a speedy joint procurement
of essential supply such as medical
equipment
for the vaccination we are proposing
today to extend for another six months
the vit exemptions for the purchase of
vaccines and testing kids
and we call on member states to
facilitate travel
when necessary so we ask
to work together on an eu passenger
locator form
we need to maintain for now restrictions
on traveling to the eu
but today we encourage member states to
make it
easier for couples and for families for
example to reunite
we also propose to extend the green
lanes beyond road freight
to rail air and water
and finally in line with our eu
vaccination strategy of the 15th of
october
we call on member states to prepare now
national vaccination plans and to review
them
now at eu level we need to be prepared
for the arrival of the first vaccines
there's a lot to do
there are many many issues to be
considered for an effective vaccine
deployment
just think of what kind of instruct
infrastructure will be needed for the
storage for example the cold chains
that have to be established or the
question
what groups of population should be
vaccinated first
here we already gave a recommendation so
we asked the member states to work with
that
but there's one thing i will be very
clear
we will not compromise on the safety
of vaccines
there are many issues to be considered
so finally
let's not forget about our commitment
to universal and fair access to covet 19
vaccines for all
we need to continue the team europe
approach to join leadership
in the covex facility the covex facility
is a huge success
184 countries have signed up
so far we all know no one will be safe
until everyone is
safe le corona virus
nu metal proven
thank you very much president i now pass
the floor
to peter piotr
thank you very much and i'm president
and uh
good afternoon everybody i can only
stress what president rondaleian just
said uh the situation is
very serious and it risks to get worse
if we
uh you know if we don't take more urgent
and drastic measures
but the future is really in our hands
and
the numbers are really staggering um and
let's never forget that it's about
people it's about real people these uh
when we say that a million people uh are
infected in the
in the union now um the deaths are
rising also
uh last week about one third more deaths
than the week before
which means that about a thousand
europeans die per day
uh from covet um and again it's about
real people
so more and more families are
affected it's not just something that is
out there
and is marginal but the good news is
also that
mortality so the risk of dying
from covet when you're hospitalized has
been reduced by about half
as compared to the spring because we've
got more experience
and also there are some progress has
been made in terms of treatment
although we don't have really a cure yet
but think of it
if in a country 500 or a thousand people
have to be admitted to a hospital
because of covet 19
that is as if an entire hospital was
closed
and shut down for other people who need
also hospitalization for surgery for
strokes for you know whatever for cancer
treatment and so on
so this has an impact on on many many
aspects far beyond
the kovitt 19. and in addition let's not
forget that kovit is not just about
having either some kind of flu some a
cold
or end up in you know in intensive care
more and more people are now suffering
from what's called long covet from
long-term consequences and i know what
i'm talking about i had it myself and
for months
i was completely exhausted and you have
cardiac involvement
and so on and so on so it is something
that is
going to be with us for quite a while
now where are we going
uh and as i mentioned we really uh
frankly and it's sobering at the
beginning of this epidemic which
let's not forget um you know nobody had
heard of it didn't exist
at the beginning of the year it's hard
to imagine that there was a world before
but it's true
and um in reality uh there's only one
virus that infects
us humans that has been eradicated and
that is smallpox
that's all and with polio we are quite
you know
we're quite close but the good news is
that
every country has demonstrated
in the spring that it can suppress the
spread of this virus
by the lockdowns and other measures so
that's really
important and secondly we've learned a
lot we've done a lot
uh one of the most important lessons was
actually that we must act fast
we should not waste our time and we
should certainly not wait until
people start dying in in in great
numbers
because that follows
about three four weeks after there isn't
a surge an increase
in new infections so and that is for
sure
just as night follows day um we need to
act
when the number of cases uh is
increasing not when people are
dying but you know the the resurgence
that we're seeing now
after the initial successes over the
summer shows
how fragile these gains are we
kind of relax too much the the measures
that are basically uh about behavior
uh then we are paying a high price and
that's what uh
is you know the risk that we are having
now and also we've learned that there
are no silver bullets
i wish there were just one thing and
then no it is really as the president
said
you know an ensemble of
measures but it only works if everybody
applies them if only a minority of
people for example wears a mask
and it's the average in the european
union is about sixty percent
uh that doesn't have that much impact uh
it and long
you know we need to go to about 95
percent that's what they do in singapore
for example
and that could save hundreds of
thousands of lives if we all do it
the third point i'd like to make here
for the future is that
um it's not about public health
or the economy or versus the economy
a recent analysis that was published in
the financial times
clearly showed that those countries that
have the highest mortality
and you know and had the biggest problem
with uh with kovit
they also have the highest political
economic damage
measured as a decline in in gdp
so we really need to fix the health
issue
in order to make sure that the economy
can you know restart
and can thrive and lastly
um one issue that i'm con concerned
about that also the president mentioned
is a corona and uh fatigue which i
fully understand you know it's a big
difference when you say okay we're going
to
be in lockdown for a month or so or two
months
and then after that everything will be
fine but i'm afraid that that's not the
case we are now talking about
much longer efforts and so involving
people the citizens is really key now
how do we get out of this and um
theoretically there are four options
that i can think of
one is that by some miracle the virus
changes and becomes
innocuous you know less infectious and
less fatal
unlikely to happen but you never know
and the virus doesn't mutate that much
fortunately secondly um you know
what there is a lot of talk about
so-called herd immunity in other words
people say okay
let people get infected particularly the
young because they die less
and then the virus will no longer have
people to infect
unfortunately um first of all let's
not forget that in europe even in the
most affected cities for example
well over 85 percent of people are still
susceptible so it takes a long time
before we go to a level of
about 60 70 percent that will be needed
to protect everybody
um but also let's not forget that the
the the toll in deaths will be enormous
millions of people will die
and i think in our 21st century that's
not something that we can
ethically uh you know accept the third
option is that
we go into lockdowns for a long long
time
but that would all push us into poverty
so we need to really have measured
approaches and lastly and that's where
there's
light at the end of the tunnel and that
is a vaccine
all vaccines as we heard from uh
president from the land
and um you know the there are
lots of vaccines in development
unprecedented scientific
effort about anybody in the vaccine
field is
doing everything they can to develop a
vaccine 11 are in clinical trials
and i'm quite hopeful that by the end of
the year we will know at least
how effective some of these vaccines
will be
and the commission has done a fantastic
job i would say
in terms of ensuring that you know by
agreements with companies that are
developing these vaccines
that every citizen will have access and
potential access to vaccines there will
be enough for everybody
however we still need to go through the
process of
making sure that we have effective
and safe vaccines and
no shortcuts as president from the lion
said
so that means first of all we need to
demonstrate that they protect
and that requires clinical trials that
involve
30 60 to 100 000 people
and we need to make sure that they
protect everybody including the elderly
who are the most vulnerable to die
that's the first thing and we don't know
how long the immunity
will last one year five years lifelong
we don't know secondly safety absolutely
no compromise there and so very careful
follow-up of everybody who is enrolled
in the studies but also
afterwards when the vaccines are on the
market
we'll need to make sure that we
carefully monitor
vaccine and that again is best done
through in a centralized way each
country does it of course but then
that we know at the european level that
we know immediately
when there are problems so that we can
act and
then there is also the fact that we need
enough of these vaccines
again for europe hundreds of millions
for the world billions
and so there is a concerted effort of uh
industry of the public sector to make
sure that
enough doses will uh be produced but
that's not only the vaccine but also
think of it
hundreds of millions of glass files of
syringes and
limit and then there's a distribution as
the president said we need to put in
place now
systems so that citizens can be
vaccinated
and that is a logistic challenge but
some countries have
very good uh vaccination programs we can
build on that
but it will be good to to test it out uh
and
in a european test day for to make sure
that we
we learn where all the the issues are
the hurdles are and finally
will people accept the vaccine and here
i'm very worried because
um recent data from service showed that
up to 25 percent of people say i will
not take that vaccine i don't trust it
and so we need to make sure of course
that the vaccines are safe and effective
but also
do a big job in terms of communication
and finally
you know i believe that the uh
commission has really stepped up to the
challenge
uh quite early on and we heard it from
president from the land
and it goes from procurement of
uh you know from tests to protective
equipment
but also now the guaranteed access
to uh to vaccines that are going to come
but also in terms of harmonizing
how various member states are
dealing with this particularly when it
comes to cross-border
uh issues and i agree that uh sharing
data
sharing information is going to be uh be
critical
um and for me it really illustrates the
value added of europe
and over european action because
let's not have any illusion this is not
going to be over until it's over
everywhere
so that is really important and at the
same time we need to
prepare for the long-term strengthen
institutions
in each country at the european level
from the european center for disease
control
european medicines agency but also
making sure there is a mechanism to
support
and accelerate innovation and research
for the next pandemic and for the next
generation of vaccines
so to conclude the
it's very serious but the future of this
epidemic is in our hands
and we can do it it depends on action at
the
national level leadership is extremely
important in this
kind of issue that affects the whole of
society
but in each community in its business
you need religious entity um and each
individual
this is a an issue where by
protecting ourselves we also protect the
whole community and i can't think of
something that is
more of a win-win to say that way and
so a long way to go but i think that
um we it depends really on the actions
that we're taking now
whether we will make europe safe again
from this epidemic thank you very much
for listening
thank you very much professor piatt
we're now going to move to the q a
session
i would ask our colleagues for the media
only to keep their hand raised in the
system
if your question is on today's
health package that we are presenting
secondly i would ask you to please
identify yourself and the media you work
for when asking your question
and thirdly to identify clearly whom you
are addressing
your question to and we start
with thomas gutshot thomas you have the
floor
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
b phil dank
i pass the floor now to david carretta
david
we merci david carretta radio
italian
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so first of all this is a process where
all of us have learned a lot and
indeed we have asked in many different
circumstances
member states to coordinate better and
to inform but if we look how far we have
gotten how
many systems we have in place now and i
was referring to them
initially then we have increased a lot
in the quality of cooperation and in the
speed of cooperation
look at the joint procurement programs
look at the different plans we have
whether it's the testing strategy or the
vaccination strategy
but also the preparedness strategy from
the 15th of july
so all in this are valuable information
for the member states we have systems in
place
like the color code that would not have
been
possible if we would not have joined
forces
and the same goes for the vaccine itself
so the advanced purchase agreements we
have now
with uh pharmaceutical companies
in europe would not have been possible
if we would not had have acted as
27 with tasking the european commission
to negotiate
these advanced purchase agreements and
here
for example is i think for you as
information
important and good to know that
we have now if we look at the numbers
that are potentially as vaccine doses
for the citizens of europe in best case
scenarios best case scenarios
we could see monthly deliveries of about
20 to 15 million doses of vaccines
the moment the first companies start to
signal that they are on the road
the big numbers of supplies are due to
start in april
um so we have been building a portfolio
of
vaccine candidates this would not have
been possible if the european union
would not have been standing there
united
as demanding towards the pharmaceutical
companies
to to comply with us and
to come to a final contract
if we look at the best case scenario
with all the different candidates
vaccine candidates we have
then we would have over the course of
the 2021
about billion doses of vaccines
of course we know that not every
candidate
will be a success so this is the extreme
best case scenario number but it shows
that there is a precautionary
wide range of access to the vaccines
we have here for the european citizen
and not only for the european citizen
but also for low and middle income
countries
this is the topic of the kovacs
facility in the best case scenario so
different vaccines are successful
in our portfolio we could vaccinate
700 million people this is more than
necessary
in the european union would include also
our donations to low and middle income
countries i am
very much opposed to a blame
game who does it well and who doesn't do
so well
because in this pandemic what we see
we're all learning
to deal with the virus and
the whole world is learning to deal with
a virus we have gotten better
the numbers for example that we've shown
at the very beginning show that
for example in the treatment for example
in mainly the treatment in hospitals
we have improved we have made
experiences and
the medical doctors and the caring
personnel
knows better how to deal with that
but in a situation where there's a lot
of learning ahead of us
i'm strong opposing to blame the one and
to praise the other
it's a mixture of many different
actions that have to put be put together
in order to be successful in fighting
this virus and
learning to live with this virus till we
have a
sufficient effective and safe vaccine
the recovery plan um
750 billion we have right now
started with the shore package 100
billion
the first tranches have been
decided yesterday
for spain for example for italy and for
poland other member states
are having access to the first tranches
too so this will help at the moment
but then we have ahead of us 750 billion
of next generation eu where we have
the duty to invest it in a way that
it will help to recover but also build
our resilience
in the european green deal in the
digitalization
so there's a huge package ahead of us
and i think we should first of all
deal with that before we talk about
other options
thank you very much i now pass the floor
parola christian spielmann
um
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
so um what the timing with the vaccines
is concerned i think
it is important to go a little bit in
depth
and afterwards peter i would appreciate
um if you compliment um
so at a certain point in time the first
pharmaceutical company will be there
with a vaccine
that then goes through the necessary
clinical trials
and it might be till the end of the year
that one
of the pharmaceutical companies is able
to go
into that stage but it will take
time and this is important to
communicate that early enough
till a vaccine is tested
in a way that we say it's effective and
safe
and with effective i mean it creates
immunity
to a certain degree not every vaccine
creates 100 percent immunity
but it may be that it's a 70
immunity it's maybe even less this
is so with the first generation of
vaccines
and this shows that a diverse portfolio
of different vaccines
that are in the short run in different
stages
is and was so important for us as
european union
to uh secure
in other words the vaccine is
not the miraculous event
that changes all from one day to the
next
it is the light at the end of the tunnel
but it takes
several steps before we see full light
at the end of the tunnel and
apart from the vaccine question
i think that this year's christmas will
be a different christmas
a lot depends on our behavior
from the individual each individual
on the regional level on the
member state level and on the european
level
how we pull through this together in the
next weeks
but it will be a different christmas
what your questions on the hospitals is
concerned
most member states took the experience
from the first
from the first wave and prepared better
during summer
the production for example of
ventilators has
drastically increased but true is too
that the health care workers
are exhausted they are in this since
march and yes it is a very very
difficult situation and therefore the
more
important is that we share the data on
the situation in the healthcare sector
and
mainly in the icu so that we have
together
transparency and an overview on the
european level
in order to act and react in a
coordinated way
and you hear from my words that the
whole
journey in this pandemic
has been that we learned together we
were always stronger
when we did it coordinated on a european
level
there are many many topics where we have
successes
but we know this is a long fight we're
in that
for a long haul and therefore
we have to keep spirits up
in vigilance in compliance and of course
in
the coordinated action we have
professor piotr
mercy we
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
um
thank you very much i now pass the floor
to naomi o'leary
you have the floor
thank you for taking my question my
question if possible is for both
um president fondueline and also dr pio
so my question is why has the strategy
in europe
failed thank you
could we ask you to repeat your question
sorry we had a little
problem at our end
certainly no problem my question is both
for uh president vonderline and dr peel
if possible
it is why has the strategy in europe
failed
thank you
so
this pandemic
[Music]
has hit us in a way that if you look
back
you can see that
a lot of things were done in the right
direction in the first wave
but um obviously the
exit strategies were partly too fast
and measures were relaxed
too soon so
that there is a second wave and
we do not know whether this is the last
wave
is also a characteristic of a pandemic
it's not the first time that this is
visible
so if you look in the history books you
see that this is a classical symptom
and we have been able in the first
part of the year to effectively reduce
the spread of the virus but
then we see that after the summer
the increase took place again
partly exponentially so now we have
we can act with the experience
of the first half of the year so we have
an advantage in knowledge
we know better what works and as i said
we are
in several fields better prepared and
therefore it is now
so important to be stringent
to stay coordinated to
act fast and to act
intensive and coherent
because this is a challenge that the
whole world is facing
so um we will be in this for quite a
while
and therefore i think a
summary judgment is
not yet due but only when
we've overcome this crisis
professor piot do you want to add
anything to this
yeah i agree with president elaine so
personally
i i think originally we were confronted
with something that
nobody had ever been confronted with
before let's not forget that so we were
learning very
fast and we're learning while we were
doing or i always say learning why we're
racing
and so um i think that worked initially
relatively well but then
personally i probably was too optimistic
in terms of how people in general
would you know continue to respect
certain basic rules of social distancing
and soul masks
and that's where i think in the summer
uh we probably should have
uh done more um as they say in english
you know that
you repair the roof when the sun shines
and
that's when uh probably collectively we
should have
put more effort in testing and tracing
but the jury is still out
i i would say that um i agree i mean i
think
we need to look forward now we need to
also
appreciate certain things like
the enormous stress on people's
livelihoods
on people's lives the mental uh health
issues and so on of these measures
and and on the other hand we there is a
need to
[Music]
to combat this epidemic and as i
mentioned you know if we
don't get the epidemic under control
there's no way that the economy
can revive um so that tension how to
manage that
is unprecedented but the the
key now is that we you know
there's no time to waste no time to lose
to put in place all these measures
the question is for how long can we go
to a system
where you have um let's say
what they called in singapore like
circuit breaker
for a few weeks time and then have a bit
more relaxed and then go back
i mean the biggest problem um for
both individuals but also for companies
for institutions for governments
is the difficulty in planning you know
whether it's planning for
i don't know your wedding or planning
for
uh you know the the budget for next year
etc
and so i you know this is something we
need to also
think so can can we do that in a more
way and i don't have an answer to it
but at the moment i think what this is a
strong case
for um better coordination that sounds
very boring but
in this case it's essential and can save
lives at the european level
to harmonize certain approaches and um
to quickly quickly learn from each other
so that
whenever we think that we have a better
idea or
something doesn't work or next door that
we you know we can
we can take measures that are
appropriate um
and and also looking beyond um europe
both in terms of what not to do and
uh and and what may work and and i'm
convinced when you look at
like east asia and southeast asia
there's a very strong sense of community
and and perhaps that's what we also need
to
to come back to in europe uh uh i know
this is now sounds like
not very measurable but at the end of
the day this is what it's going to take
to defeat this virus
and also to accept the vaccine and to
you know build a new society again
over thank you we now move to
griselda pastor
zelda quick question please
[Music]
so um to answer uh the first question
um the rapid tests are now coming to the
market
um we have today put forward a testing
strategy and we will work more
intensively and come out in a couple of
weeks
with a more detailed concept what the
rapid tests are concerned
the rapid tests have a big advantage
they are fast they are cheap and
therefore they can fit into a certain
hole because when you get
the question when you get the result is
also a crucial one
of course the gold standard are the pcr
tests
but the rapid antigen tests can
complement
very well they are not
as reliable as the pcr tests
so because they are not as good as the
pcr tests
to find to detect an infection when
there is there are no symptoms and there
is
a low virus load
but they have their advantages what
speed is concerned and
what mass testing is concerned in a
population where you have a
high level of infection or in a
situation environment where you have a
high level of infection so
the it's not only one test there are
different ones what we also are going to
do
is evaluate the different tests so that
we have a better idea uh what the
quality is of the different ones
and can give this advice to the member
states
thank you um
oh sorry professor piotr do you want to
add something
um we can judy
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
acceptable
philippe
um
[Music]
is
[Music]
me
so i think what the quality of testing
is concerned
this is a classical question for peter
piott
i think not only one test or one type of
test
is what takes it all but
they are complementary and i think
professor piotr is the right one
to detail that out as this is the last
question
we've gone through the different
measures to fight
this virus together as 27 member states
450 million
citizens of europe and the
the the difficult task to coordinate
every new
step that we're learning over time
but i want to emphasize there's another
side to the european union too
and this is where the european union the
european commission has a classical
competence
compared to the health sector and that
is the single market and the economic
side
and i think we also should be aware
of the fact that in an unprecedented way
this time
europe has acted we flexibilized all
structural fund we triggered the
general escape clause we have now the
sure
package in case and i guess many regions
of
the world would love it to have such a
possibility to support
short time work in a critical stage in
healthy companies
and we have next generation you
unprecedented in volume
unprecedented in structure and
it is for the first time that in such a
severe crisis
different to 10 or 12 years ago it is
not an
intergovernmental solution but it's a
true european
solution so as difficult as time are
times are here are positive sides
that are classical european it is the
european way to do it
and i think we should also keep that in
mind
professor piotr
[Music]
technology
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
thank you very much professor thank you
very much president this brings us to
the end
of today's press conference as i said at
the beginning
the president will be back in the press
room on the 1st of december so
for many of you who unfortunately did
not have the opportunity of asking a
question today there is another
opportunity
in a short time thank you very much have
a nice afternoon
you